cause you know eventually he'll come
around and he'll love me the way I want
to be loved no leave these kind of
sisters stay the hell away from them
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you and the shall
American award click the link and donate
what you can salaam alaikum guys many
people or some people think that Ali
dawa is so off the controversy that he
started the bitter to show the marriage
documentary and all this stuff that he
does for the views and the life not
really I do this stuff because I see a
direct threat to the family unit and I
started these projects in place and put
them in place so we can combat that and
this sister who I used to follow because
I like to learn and understand marriage
counseling what it might be you know I
think this is a psychologist I don't
know what she's I don't know what she's
for that matter here's what happened yes
and this video was sent to me by Sister
Naima B Robertson hamdullah and I asked
all of you guys to follow the likes of
her and the sister Fatima and like uh
many sisters like her and stay away from
sisters like this woman that I'm going
to show you why here is a video and
listen damn carefully to her advice to
our Muslim sisters
the woman for that matter and look how I
messaged her she deleted my comment not
that she banned she blocked me for what
what did I say let's listen and tell me
if I'm wrong let's listen inshallah here
we go if you've the job of explaining to
somebody how to love you and communicate
with your needs it is not your job to
stick around and just hope that they're
gonna get it or it's gonna click in
their head at some point and be patient
because you know eventually he'll come
around and he'll love me the way I want
to be loved no leave I mean you cannot
make this stuff up are you kidding me if
you have communicated to your partner
your husband who loves you we're talking
about a hospice husband please don't put
this husbands or these fathers in the
country without abuse me please put them
away for now for God's sake yeah a
husband who works for you who goes and
provides for you who loves you takes
care looks after your family yes and for
some odd reason if you feel like he's
not loving you the way you should be
lost whatever it may be this changes
from Woman to Woman yes women emotional
creatures they can have an emotional
moment where they feel like they're not
being loved a woman goes through
menopause she goes for pregnancy she
goes through a period so many emotional
things she can be easily influenced a
few words can look this is the fact this
is a so just imagine our sister who
just had a bad day with her husband
whatever it may be something minor she
feels like she's not being loved the way
she is and she comes across this sister
and what does she say if you have tried
to communicate and tell him how to love
you and blah blah blah blah blah okay
what shall I do and he's not listening
huh what should I do just leave are you
out of your mind are you crazy eighty
percent of the time women already
initiate divorce that's what Allah has
given the power of tala to us because we
begin every flipping two seconds yeah
that's how they created that's why the
prophet peace before he said they're
like a bent rib if you try to spray
straighten it it'll break so we accept
them how they are and if you think about
it as mad as husbands we do put up with
that they put up with us in certain
things that we do or we put up with that
we have to as men a real man deals with
it like a real man this woman is out
there without fear of Allah telling
women who already initiated 80 of
divorce and if their college graduated
or whatever it costed 90 can you imagine
this is a massive problem this is a joke
eighty percent of time women initiate
divorce and they end up regretting it
yes now and now she's saying just leave
casually just leave yallah
calm just leave destroy your family
these kind of sisters I'm not saying
she's doing it intentionally stay the
hell away from them do not listen to
this Google Assistant I'm not going to
give a name yeah because I don't want to
get hate comments I can't control people
I'm not asking anyone to give a hate but
people just gonna do weird stuff okay
stop it I don't want anyone to attack
her say anything to her what I'm just
saying is stay away from her now what
did I message her I left this comment
yeah and check this out if I say
anything wrong here we go guys yeah
assalamu alaikum sister I'm respectful
I've seen some of your stuff and and
it's beneficial but this advice is
terrifying to hear how can you so calmly
encourage someone and to end their
relationship because they try to
communicate their feelings and the other
person didn't understand do you know how
many couples can apply this to
themselves when this probably doesn't
even apply to them women already
initiate 80 of divorces and you are
further encouraging them over Petty
issues this is no reason for any partner
be he man or a woman to leave please be
careful what you put what you put up
these videos destroy households what
does she do did she say brother thank
you for your advice let me take you on
board you know maybe you had a point
there let me reflect on that no I got
blocked I got blocked yes and I left the
comment my comment got deleted these
kind of women stay the hell away from
them I'm seeing it sisters and brothers
and make sure if you hear this woman's
voice and your wife is watching
Instagram tell your wife to stop
listening simple as they destroy
households they destroy families kids
broken families because of these kind of
irresponsible self-proclaimed whatever
she is to come and outright to just
leave can you imagine if I've done a
video and said Brothers if you try to
communicate
Etc give it just leave
how dare you shame on you for not even
taking a CR blocking me I don't give a
damn if you block me I don't give a damn
that's not the point fear Allah and
these kind of sisters be whoever they
are man male or female should be
boycotted outright stay the hell away
from breaking the family unit down
subhanallah anyways guys that's all I
have to say on the 15th of July the
bitter trip show we are filming our new
episodes inshallah we are looking for
two cultures we have a culture episodes
which is inviting those from different
cultures Somali Bengali Pakistani
Moroccan Algerian Turkish Kurdish
everybody so that'll be culturally
meaning please this is from the Moroccan
community and three brothers memorial
Community we'll be talking about the
Moroccan culture the Somali culture uh
the winners were we we did a poll um it
was bengoli and then Moroccan but uh
bengales have been applying so I'm glad
we're doing the Somali and Moroccan so
brothers please apply and sisters the
Moroccans and somalis if you want to be
a part of it on 15th of July please
apply at the bittertruthshow gmail.com
and we've got a couple of more spaces
left inshallah and we want to know more
about your culture and so people can
benefit from it as well inshallah that's
all I have to say my brothers and
sisters says may Allah bless you guys
till next time
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadakhajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
reward click the link and donate what
you can